Oh wonderful to be here nice to see
everybody we do stand-up comedy for long
enough at some point someone will come
up and ask you how you do it because it
seems like a hard thing to do to get up
in front of a roomful of strangers and
talk but it's not because you guys are
so amazing and I'm not trying to butter
you up
I'm not stand up comedy crowds are
amazing you'll put up with anything just
to see where it's going eventually
right like you guys are like a wise
sassy black judge on a courtroom TV show
like this is weird as hell but I want to
see where it's going I'll allow it
I'll allow it proceed with your
hyperbolic analogy counselor hey I found
out I was sad the other day I didn't
even know I was sad does this ever
happen to you I found out I was sad and
the way I found out I was sad was I was
at a jack-in-the-box
that could be the whole story
but there's more I was at a
jack-in-the-box and I pull up to the
window to collect my order and the woman
working the drive-through at
jack-in-the-box that night looked me up
and down and with tenderness and mercy
in her voice she said oh are you doing
okay let me say that again the woman
working the drive-through and a
jack-in-the-box hamburger restaurant
felt like she had to ask me if I was
going to be okay and it's not like I put
in a concerning order either I didn't
pull up to the window and it was like
give me tacos until my dad is proud of
me it was just a standard
jack-in-the-box order and she had to see
if I was going to be okay you know how
many sad faces she sees every single
night it's the same amount of faces she
sees every single night nobody's having
a great day and then goes to
jack-in-the-box that never happens
nobody's ever been like what a fun first
day this has been amazing I didn't even
know LA had AZ do you want to go get
some of those egg rolls they make it
have leftover taco ingredients never
jack-in-the-box is depressing xanax
should be on the dollar menu
jack-in-the-boxes commercials should
just be the last 15 minutes of the movie
Old Yeller that's it
just the last 15 of old yeller and then
Jack walking out like we're open all
right I have a girlfriend which is weird
because I look like I'm in the middle of
a really bad breakup my girlfriend is
way better at arguing than me she's
amazing and arguing she'd come over
these very eloquent ways to express
exactly how she feels like we'll be
arguing she'll be like I feel like you
don't even know who I am do you you
don't know me I'm just a book and you
looked at the cover that's all that you
did you just looked at the cover you
didn't open up the book you didn't read
the table of contents you don't know the
plots or the storylines or the
characters but guess what Ian here's the
Cliff's Notes for my heart
maybe you should crack over the book
sometime maybe you'll read about
something you love
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're right I'll get the groceries out
of the car I'm sorry I mean I'm a
comedian I can come up with metaphors
but my metaphors don't do you any good
when you're fighting with your
girlfriend will be arguing and I'll be
like oh yeah you a book is that what you
are well maybe you don't know who I am
because lately I've been feeling like a
big block with a question mark on it and
you're a Mario who can't jump high
enough yeah what's in the block a
mushroom a corn a feather a flower a
star a different kind of mushroom
there's a lot of mushrooms in here
sweetheart
I'm sorry for yelling I'll get the
groceries that's on me what's up hi I'm
29 years old so now when I start dating
someone I have to think about whether or
not this is somebody I want to start a
family with and I don't know if I want
to I have friends who have kids and I
don't want to become like them I don't
like because when they get together all
they ever do is talk about how brilliant
their children are you don't I mean
they'll be hanging out and they'll be
like bergamont here it's already reading
Melville
he's only four years old we tried to
start him out on something easier but he
said no it has to be Melville well he
said it in Mandarin but we understood
somebody else like oh my god that's
amazing well chartreuse here is only
three and she's already playing Bach
concertos on the harpsichord so I think
it's because when I was breastfeeding
her I would grind up Baby Einstein CDs
and drink those before I gave her the
record and somebody else will be like oh
my god that's amazing well I'm still
pregnant with a little Chuck Palahniuk
here that's their full first name Fight
Club author Chuck Palahniuk and even
though I'm still pregnant with her I've
been putting unsolved Rubik's cubes into
my the try
[Applause]
they've been coming out saw